all right shiny for python interactive
apps and dashboards made easy-ish
um I am the CTO of company formerly
known as rstudio now known as positive
shiny is both old and new shiny for R
has been around since 2012 and just
coincidentally
uh yesterday was the 10-year anniversary
of the blog post introducing shining so
happy birthday shiny
but Chinese for python is uh
right out of the oven so we just
announced this a few months ago at our
studio conf this summer and it is still
Alpha software now that being said
there's still an enormous amount of
power in this framework uh even at this
relatively early stage so I'm really
excited to share some of that with you
today
so what is shiny shiny is a framework
for creating interactive apps and
dashboards in Python
and it is designed primarily with data
scientists in mind and that is a couple
of uh ramifications first of all we
don't expect you to have any web
development skills so no HTML CSS or
JavaScript
and we use this reactive programming
approach to interactivity that I'm going
to talk a lot about today and it's
designed to be easy to use for people
who have a data background
now that being said
I'm not a data scientist I'm a software
engineer I've been building websites for
25 years now and the thought of working
full time on a framework that was like
lowest common denominator or like kind
of guard rails everywhere would be
really frustrating for me so I also
designed shiny with me and mine or we
design shiny with me in mind so if you
do have HTML CSS and JavaScript skills
which it seems like increasing numbers
that people do these days and you can
fully leverage them to extend and
customize your shiny apps and this
reactive programming uh model that we're
going to talk about today is is not just
easy to get started with it's also
powerful flexible indeed and that's
going to be a big focus of my talk today
so uh before I get into this there is
going to be a bunch of code that I'm
going to show today and I want to
reassure you uh this is not a lean
forward kind of a presentation this is
some more sort of Lean Back and You're
not expected to be able to like read
every line and be able to internalize
this that's not that's mostly not what
this talk is about there will be a
couple places where I'll let you know if
it's time to pay closer attention but
this is all going to be a pretty broad
brush Strokes so each shiny app is
composed of two main parts
uh first you declare your user interface
so this is uh python code that generates
HTML that will determine what your UI
looks like
and this literally just generates HTML
that's what that app UI variable would
print
and then secondly you have a server
portion which again python code and this
is the code that provides the
interactivity to your app so it says
what is going to happen when you move
inputs and need outputs to be updated
and then finally some boilerplate at the
bottom to create these two pieces
together into a shiny app object
um if you weren't on that code this is
what it would look like you you could
paste that code into uh vs code and then
if you install the shiny for python
extension to vs code you could hit that
play button and it'll show it in a
window on the right
now let me show you an example of a more
complicated user interface and this is
still not very complicated but there are
a few more elements than just those uh
the one input and the one output this is
an air mass calculator that uses the
Astro High python package to give you
information about when it's a good time
to look for whatever celestial objects
in this guy you're interested in making
observations about so you tell it what
date you plan to go out and look at
things and then the latitude and
longitude that you're operating from you
can click on the map if you want and uh
of course the objects that you intend to
observe and it gives you these uh these
plots as well as the sunrise sunset and
sunrise time uh for those for that day
so again this is sort of like lean back
don't worry about all this code but I
wanted to show that uh there are all
sorts of different types of functions
you can use in a shiny UI so this is raw
HTML in Python form so that is an H3 tag
for a heading uh you can put some
markdown in there rows and columns that
you can Nest arbitrarily
and then of course we have outputs and
we have inputs
now I also want to sort of zoom out on
this code
and there's sort of a shape to it right
uh shiny UI is made out of nested
function calls and this is a really nice
property because it means that the shape
of our code sort of mirrors the shape of
the Dom that's being created in our UI
so in this case the top chunk of the
code is the header and then you can see
it sort of has this sibling in terms of
the indentation and that's the body and
that's mirrored in the shape of the UI
and then within this body there's two
columns and it's the same thing in the
UI so as your uis it more and more
complicated it's really nice that the
shape of the code gives you a real big
hint as to where you need to go look in
your code to figure out where the
certain button is or or what have you
so
this summer we announced training for
Python and we had been operating on it
uh in secret so uh of course when it was
announced it made it to Reddit so our
shining is coming to Python and uh
people had a variety of reactions
some people were excited
uh and other people said this
but it's just so easy to throw something
up with streamlined and this is a uh an
idea that has come up again and again
since our announcement
um it's funny I I don't hear it so much
about other python app Frameworks but
over and over again but streamlit is
just so easy
so first I want to examine is streamlit
really that easy uh how many people here
have used streamlit
okay yeah yeah if my question if you
stay exactly within what streamlin is
really good for it's fine
but if you want to do something just a
little bit different you buy your head
for for days I'm gonna ask you not to
give away the rest of my talk please
so just so easy let's say this example
of you have a straightforward analysis
script that goes beginning to end right
maybe you export it from an iPad IP or
something like that
the promise of streamlit is that you can
take pretty much that same exact code
sprinkle in some streamlit and boom
interactive application now compare that
to shiny which uh even the little that
you know from my previous couple of
slides shiny has a shape that your app
needs to fit into it has an app UI
server and you need to put your code
into that chicken
so
uh
how were they able to do this how are
they able to make their code or or their
apps look so much like Scripts
and we had a couple of really big ideas
and the biggest idea by far is this on
every user interaction we run the entire
app from beginning to end so if you move
a slider if you click a button anything
you do beginning to end beginning to end
and input controls are both declared and
red with the same line of code now this
is not a session not streamlined so I'm
not going to teach you ins and outs but
but just take my word for it that these
two points are really big ideas and they
go together you can't really have one
without the other
and they also include a bunch of clever
State Management and diffing on both
sides of uh of the wire to make this all
feel very seamless to feel like you're
in this um single page app
and it works it is as easy as advertise
no question I mean they're getting
started is incredible like you you could
write a stream at falling out of bed you
might write one by accident
okay which really does it's a fair
question then
why shiny from python in a world where
streamlit exists and by the way when
people ask this question there's almost
two questions being asked right like
number one why should I invest my time
in learning about shiny for python when
I know streamlit
um
but then the second question is like why
are you bothering why are you spending
your time creating this uh this
framework where no need exists
so
um as the gentleman alluded to the
design of streamlined it works extremely
well for simple and or small apps but
but when you get to even moderately
ambitious apps uh the same design that
makes it so easy becomes a liability
so that's a problem for us at our studio
now pause it because for the last 10
years our users have been doing stuff in
shiny and what we've seen is that people
want to create ambitious house they have
cool things that they're doing their
work is complicated and the apps that
they create reflect the reality of their
work and uh we're not just seeing people
use shiny for uh throwaway apps or uh
you know demonstrations of simple
statistical techniques to undergrads
although there's plenty of that but also
I mean people are building businesses
around their shiny ass people are
relying on shiny for key workflows in
Pharma and Finance in manufacturing and
uh the idea that we would build we would
give them the tools to build up to a
certain level and then no further that
is super frustrating for me
so in order to explore this further I
want to take a step back and talk about
what even is an interactive dashboard or
app like what is the problem that both
streamlined and shiny have to solve and
it's basically some version of this
we've got a browser
we've got a server that's running Python
and when the user does stuff in the
browser that results in inputs being
sent to the server
and when the server receives those
inputs it's responsibility is to come up
with uh changing outputs it needs to
create or update outputs in response to
that input
and if you think of the server as a
black box
the browser doesn't really care how it
comes up with those answers they just
need to be right
and just for completeness there's other
things that server might do that don't
resolve in outputs changing but are
still important like writing to a
database or posting to an API
now let's get a little more concrete and
this is where I will ask you to lean in
a little bit and this is just picture
this being a Jupiter uh style analysis
that you're doing that executes from
from top to bottom you've got a bunch of
parameters these are things that you're
likely to want to change okay I'll look
for the data set you're analyzing what's
the X and Y columns we're going to take
a look at what's a color map we're going
to use to plot it with and how many rows
are we going to use to preview the data
further down
uh in cell two it loads the data as a
CSV uh cell three it just grabs a couple
of columns off of the data frame to
create a new data frame and then four
and five it previews the data just the
first n rows and then plots it using
that color map okay like super simple
that you know you've probably done this
like three times this week already
so uh
what we really have here if you look at
it through the lens of an interactive
app is the top are inputs right those
are things that the user is going to
want to change and then see things
happen
and the things at the bottom are outputs
these are like cells that actually show
you something
and in between these are intermediate
values right people don't see them they
just see the effects that they have on
the outputs
so how does streamlit deal with this as
inputs change what a stream went through
restart the runoff restart run all
restarting on all that's that is the um
the only model that it supports is that
it just constantly reruns this thing
and that uh is fine for a lot of apps
right and it's fine for a lot of Jupiter
notebooks if your data is small if your
everything happens quickly then no big
deal but if that data is a 20 minute CSV
then uh it's leaving some performance on
the table like if this y call changes
Okay so
three uses lipol so that's going to
affect what happens if you have two and
then df2 is used in these two places so
for sure we have to re-execute these
these three cells but we don't have to
execute and read CSV and yet streamlit
is going to do that anyway
now we can do an even more example with
nro because this is used for only just
grabbing the top and row uh rows off the
top of the data frame so that's a super
cheap thing and yet once again uh
extremely doesn't realize this and it's
going to execute the entire thing
okay
so as you can see there is this sort of
fundamental mismatch between uh what
streamlined is doing and these sort of
opportunities to do things uh faster and
it's not just about performance there is
also
um flow control and State Management is
also compromised by this very simple
model and um
I've done it it feels a little weird to
like bring up complaints about somebody
else's software and I don't love this
but I just want to make it clear that
this is not something that I am
inventing uh because I'm trying to make
myself look good uh this is uh it is a
serious problem once you get to a
certain point with your stream with apps
so uh these are all things that uh
pretty
um
experienced streamlined apps have said
and you know to a person they all still
say I love streamlined I love streamlit
it is definitely not meeting my needs
anymore with this run everything all the
time model
okay so let's take a look at what shiny
does
so
if you look at the relationship between
these different cells and start drawing
lines where one cell affects another
cell you'll end up with a bunch of lines
like this right
and when I see arrows like this I think
to myself that's a computational graph
and that gets me really excited because
I'm a software engineer and I know what
to do with computational graphs right so
let's take this same information and
spread it out across two Dimensions we
end up with something like this and now
this is very clearly a graph
this is the Holy Grail if we can have
this information these blue arrows then
it's very easy to go from any of the
inputs that are changing and just Trace
where does that lead us and every node
We Touch needs to be re-executed right
simple graph traversal problem
uh there's just one problem
even for this like trivial example
that's a lot of arrows right and getting
those arrows right is important and in
fact
that Arrow was missing
and without that Arrow I've got one
Arrow out of all of these if the data
set changes the plot doesn't update
and that's the worst kind of error
because it's not going to show an error
message it's not going to crash it's
just going to give you the wrong answer
and data science I mean is there a worse
sin that your app framework can do and
then to give you the wrong answer
confidently
so luckily shiny does not ask you to
draw arrows all shiny asks you to do is
maintain these chunks of code so you're
not responsible for the relationships
you're just responsible for the notes
so each of these pieces each all of this
code you need to divide into chunks that
make sense for your problem and then you
have to provide a decorator that tells
shiny just a little bit of a hint about
what the purpose of this chunk is in
this case those two intermediate values
those are reactive calculations meaning
the purpose of this code is to generate
a value that's going to be used
elsewhere in this app
and then things that need to be
displayed to the user are marked with at
output and then you have to give a hint
as to what kind of output this is a
table plot UI and a number of other ones
and if you do this if you maintain these
boundaries and these uh decorators then
shiny will draw the arrows for you and
it will do it perfectly every time I can
do a whole talk just about how that part
works but that is not this talk
um now because I think that's a little
bit graphical and attract and I don't
want your imagination running away with
how difficult it is to actually you know
reproduce what you just saw I'm going to
show you uh like what what taking this
code and turning it into what shiny
wants from you to show you what that
looks like so first we're going to break
the code into chunks right and in Python
those are functions Trunks and codes for
code or functions right
and secondly because DF and df2 have
changed from values to functions
everywhere we're using DF and bf2 we
need to Now call functions right
and then third we add decorators as I
described
and then finally you put this inside of
the server function that I talked about
way in the beginning
and once you've done that then not only
do you have this uh this sort of
Newfound efficiency by only executing
the minimum amount of code necessary but
uh there it turns out that this reactive
programming model is so beautifully well
suited to this task of creating
interactive applications that for 10
years we've just been constantly
discovering new features falling out of
The Primitives that we wrote back in
2012.
I'm not going to go through all these
but just to give you an idea like these
are features that we didn't have to like
you know design carefully and then like
force through through like clever
programming tricks like these are things
that felt like we discovered properties
of reactivity just by grabbing different
um I don't know like the equivalent of
subatomic particles and being like Oh I
wonder if something nice will happen and
then boom we have like event cameras we
have time-based reactivity falling out
from that
together
so
um I think
yeah
so a few minutes left to show some demos
oh my destinations totally changed
all right
yeah I'm just assuming
okay so this first example
it's just a simple uh CPU monitor
this is just using matplot Loop to graph
each of the 10 cores on my MacBook and I
can use this Chooser to change the color
palette
I'm not sure if I put this one in there
but you can do that
uh you can freeze the output and
unfreeze it and you can choose the
number of samples and then down below I
also have a table that's formatted this
is a canvas table using Styler except
for this little blue box that's just CSS
and uh yeah we can we can change some of
these parameters while it's running
and
in order to change this from sort of
your typical
um Interactive
app where you have to move some input
for things to change to have it be sort
of streaming uh it's just this one line
so uh CPU percent Returns the current
snapshot for what your CPUs are doing
and this invalidate later says this
Valley is only good for this limited
time and when that expires then a shiny
knows to go we execute everything that
or the minimum amount necessary to get
all your outputs correct
okay
so for my second example
I didn't realize how weird this sounded
until I said it out loud during
rehearsal but uh
so I built this to teach my kids about
compound interest
that's the kind of dad that I am
uh what this app lets you do is create a
few different scenarios
that represent different savings
strategies okay
and I heard this rumor I wanted to see
if it was true it's like so I wrote this
a lot you can put an arbitrary python
expression here and that will determine
for each year how many dollars is is
contributed and then it'll grow at seven
percent interest
so we have two scenarios that are
pre-populated here the first one is uh
two thousand dollars a year until age 30
then stop
so this person only between the ages of
19 and 30 is going to contribute two
thousand dollars a year and then just
let it grow at seven percent interest
now for scenario two it's the opposite
they'll invest two thousand dollars a
year starting at 30. never stop
so the person on the left has just this
limited time to save and the person on
the right never stops saving and the
question is how long does it take
scenario two to catch up to scenario one
obviously it's not going to be you know
age 40 but is it 50 is it 60 is it 70
any guesses anyone ever seen this before
yeah the answer is never never catch us
up
which has to be super frustrating if
you're 30 years older about it
uh so uh let's let's just play with some
other scenarios like what if uh it's a
thousand dollars uh every year you're in
you're out
I just get to the end here
uh it splits the difference
so you can you can add more scenarios
here
and then you can take them away
and this ability to sort of dynamically
add and remove UI and have it still
participate in these outfits that are
already sitting on your page this is
another thing that sort of like fell out
from reactivity
okay one more demo
uh this is actually a demo that we took
from plotly and this is using the plotly
I just give it away this is using the
properly um ipy widget to display and
this is um what this is showing is
Brownian motion which is some kind of
motion that molecules do on a software
engineer
um and we're seeing this in 3D and I can
click new data to keep generating new uh
random traces here
and some of these
uh look pretty cool in others like this
or it's kind of hard to tell what's
happening because this isn't three
dimensions and this is a weird angle so
you can use your mouse to sort of drag
it around because this is hotly but um
just to do something fun instead I'm
using Google's media pipe library to
track my hand and then I can turn it
using my hand
so we're using
um you know there's code that's running
in shiny that takes these different
landmarks on my hand and generates a
normal Vector shooting out of my palm
and then tries to orient the uh the same
way
now the reason I showed you this is
because we're playing with this I was
playing with this at home and I showed
my son who is a senior in high school an
aspiring computer science major next
year and the demo originally looked like
this
so I wish they go there
I don't know if you can tell but like it
it's quite jittery
and I didn't even notice I was like can
you believe this works and he was like
why is it so jittery
[Music]
and it's a it's jittery because sensors
are jittery right uh but he you know I
thought he posted an interesting
question like can we get that to not be
so jittery and we tried a couple things
we tried like not registering any
movement unless it was more than a
certain distance and that was a
stuttering mess and then we came up with
the idea like let's just smooth it over
uh a certain number of samples like the
last five samples we'll just do a simple
meme right and uh he said well that's it
for me I'm off the bed and
um I texted him like six minutes later I
was like swimming Works super well uh it
does I mean it's a really big difference
even with this very naive uh sort of a
strategy
so he came running down and we looked at
it together and it was fantastic and uh
I'll show you this because the way I was
able to implement this uh was not
um
not a smoother that was specific for
this app but I was able to implement a
generalized reactive smoother so you
give it any reactive expression and give
it any smoothing strategy that just
takes a bunch of samples and returns one
sample and
um with just this few lines of code now
shiny apps can have smoothing on any
input
um so yeah I had written this slide
first about like all these gifts that
reactivity has to give
and it's crazy that like after 10 years
we're still discovering these uh these
things every once in a while so
uh so China python is an alpha but uh
you know we would love for you to give
it a try we would love feedback uh if
you are a streamlined user and you think
I'm full of crap I would love to hear it
I'm all the ears here I I I'm here
specifically on this QR code will be on
the next page as well
um I'm here to learn the reason I flew
out here for this conference is because
I want to meet as many of you as
possible so I will be at the positive
Booth all day tomorrow and if you have
any interest in interactive dashboards
in python or any other language I would
love to talk to you and hear your
perspective
uh and that's it
[Applause]
so I have successfully given us I think
plenty of time for questions
back there yeah so I saw that you had
one example had matplotlid the other one
had probably can you can you use any
traffic library or or you can completely
present it yeah the question is can you
use any graphing Library uh so any of
them that work with mat hotlib or have
mac plotlet as sort of the underlying
rendering engine yeah for sure uh and
I'm sorry I forgot exactly which ones
those are boring but yeah Seaborn plot
nine are certainly in that list there's
a couple others and the other thing that
we have that you saw with the plotly
example is that we have a package called
shiny widgets that is
um
it lets you embed ipy widgets into shiny
apps and not just in the sort of static
way like you get a static snapshot of
the HTML but in the sort of live
bi-directional communication way uh that
was another thing that we were able to
extend reactivity to do is to um to sort
of integrate with the ipy widget model
of communication as well that is I think
more highly experimental because
sometimes we've found that widgets work
in Jupiter but actually in some solid
way
you know break the spec of how widgets
are supposed to work so uh but almost
all the ones that I've tried work after
some fashion that being said for things
like plotly and alteran Vega that are
like really important visualization
libraries that are based in JavaScript I
think in the future you can expect us to
do
um more tightly bound Integrations that
the iPad widget stuff works great but
you are sort of moving from reactivity
to an object-oriented model and back as
you um not even object-oriented but
event-based uh so my point being that um
you know streamlined has like custom
bindings for Altair and for for all
those other ones and I think um we'll
almost certainly go down that road as
well
theoretically if you really need the
decorators to be able to draw the arrows
yeah the question was theoretically do
you need the decorators to draw the
arrows
yeah this is going to get a little bit
deeper uh into a reactivity but
these two different types of chunks that
you see here they have quite different
properties
the reactive calcs they are lazy loaded
so shiny is going to do everything it
can not to ever execute any in uh
intermediate values unless they are
necessary for outputs whereas outputs
are they aren't needed like they in and
of themselves have purpose so for that
reason like we we don't we can't just
infer what your intention is for each of
these code blocks so that's why
um we we require at least a little bit
now do those need to be
two decorators for those outputs or they
could definitely do one that was just a
choice that we made
um does that answer your question or
yeah I guess there's no way to trace
through the code and figure it out
something like that
um I'd be happy to talk to you about
this tomorrow I think we I
we could have really fun conversation
but
um I want to make sure other questions
get answered yeah
um
I've seen this kind of idea before but I
haven't heard the term it exactly like
reactive programming is this like an
emerging
uh approach kind of like and you foresee
it being something that becomes more
pervasive in the same way like async
programming has sure uh so reactive the
question was uh reactive programming
um this gentleman has never heard that
word applied to uh this kind of approach
uh so I do have to caveat and say
reactive programming means a lot of
different things at this point there are
a number of different approaches to
doing this sort of very Dynamic kind of
programming that our branded reactive
that actually behave in very different
ways this particular
um style of reactive programming is
called transparent reactive programming
and it was pioneered by I think it was
knockout and meteor JS in 2011 2012. uh
this kind of reactive programming I
think is one of the more successful ways
to write JavaScript front ends these
days so mob X and
um I forgot a couple other like very
major uh
recoil I think is another one or
something like that
um yeah like these ideas have a lot of
purchase in the JavaScript World
um but I will say like reactivity in the
in the general sense that general term I
think you can think of it as any attempt
to make the interaction between changing
and moving Parts a little more
declarative and a little less imperative
uh a lot of as long as it meets that
description a lot of people are calling
their stuff reactive programming and
uh in general that idea is on fire I
mean there there's just probably no
JavaScript framework that doesn't call
it self-reactive it's like react right
the actual framework is called react and
it turns out it's not actually reactive
and uh it's called Uh the greatest felt
did a great talk that was like react is
not reactive um so so yes it is an
extremely mainstream Concept in the
JavaScript World
um we'll see what happens in Python it
seems like people are really used to
callbacks right now and um this is you
know my first attempt to start telling
the story about why you should want
something more
all right
yes
sorry I really wanted to get back to the
QR code but this is taking forever
um
that was
yeah
um so to be clear every
uh app framework author has to make some
decisions about what's important to them
right there are very few free lunches
and the streamlined folks
um did an amazing job at what they set
out to do which was to lower the bar as
much as possible as to how much effort
it is to get started making apps
and as I as I showed like they they had
to sacrifice a lot on that altar uh and
dash has some interesting things about
it and I think the the biggest trade-off
that they made uh was in favor of making
their entire model stateless which means
there is no like this whole reactive
graph that I showed you that's all
living in memory in Python and for them
that all lives in the client
so that means like for us we're trying
to do as little work as possible to
update your outputs and for them anytime
anything needs to be recalculated any
inputs that are involved in every
calculation have to be uploaded to the
server every single time
so that CSV you know data frame that you
downloaded uh or or that you read in for
them if you want to reuse that
it's actually living in a client and
then every time you move a slider and
some outputs update each of those
outputs is getting uploaded a fresh copy
of the data uh
so you do end up with a stateless server
but at what cost now
I mean they know that this is has this
implication so they have pages about how
to work around this problem uh
but depending on the shape of your app
and I think for a lot of the shiny apps
that we've seen people build like you
just wouldn't want to fight that battle
when shiny just makes all this sort of
automatic just by programming in the way
you naturally would
so
um it's shiny lies it's shiny life can
be able to do everything that's shiny
with uh yes so uh shiny live is a uh
deployment option for shining where you
don't need a server at all uh so using
similar technology to Pi script it's
also based on pyrodite which Pi script
is based on you still have the same
exact execution model except we've just
moved the server to be running in the
background in your browser which means
from a hosting perspective you don't
have to find somewhere to park a python
process like a Roku or something you can
just put it on GitHub Pages or what have
you
um so yeah today's shiny live does does
a lot there are a couple of limitations
that are sort of inherent to running
python in the browser for example if you
need to connect to your database
directly from your shiny app that's not
something that's possible from mozam
today and even if it was what you really
want to put database credentials inside
of the client and
and there are some things that we expect
to improve with the fullness of time
like a lot of packages that are on Pipi
don't work in piadite right now uh and I
I no doubt that problem is eventually
going to be solved but for today you may
be happily deploying to Chinese live and
then realize oh I installed this package
and now I'm back in the real python
world so Winston did I miss anything
there is that um okay Woodson is a guy
who actually uh made the awesome stuff
happen I tried to talk them out of it
unfortunately I was not successful so
oh I'm sorry someone over there what
yeah you had your computer yeah so I'm
sorry but behind you
oh
yes thank you uh streamlit has a feature
called session state I'm sorry I I meant
to talk about this uh
so streamlined
they're very smart they know that this
run everything all the time has you know
these sort of
um this sort of Misfit as your as your
apps get bigger and more complicated and
uh are doing harder to execute things
and there are a bunch of different
things that they have uh deployed in
order to give you tools to hopefully get
around these things uh and I think two
of the most important ones are one
there's all sorts of caching uh
mechanisms that they give you so if
you've already uh you know run this
function with these arguments then you
can use the copy that a saved disk
instead of running it again and the
other is the session statement so
normally with a streamlit app all of
your local variables are just they're
just thrown out every time uh the script
re-executes as it would be if you were
executing a python script from the band
right so they have a feature called
session state that lets you store values
and addict that lives on between execute
stations
and people were rightfully really
excited about this and streamlit when
this came out because it does give you
like just enough of a finger hole that
you can like do you can get yourself out
of quite a lot of jams right
um but it's interesting
like I don't deny that that works for
some cases but
that kind of programming is extremely
difficult to reason about so you are now
controlling the flow of your application
using
I'll describe it as Global variables and
an unconditional go-to one right um and
that's just a really difficult model to
reason about so uh so yes I think
session state is something that they had
to do and it does let
um extremely users who are determined
keep going with streamlit for a while
longer but but I have
I I I'm sorry I don't mean to imply that
every streamlit user is going to hit
these limits I mean for some streamlined
users they might just happily want run
it every time yeah that's fine I'll you
know I'm going to build streamlined apps
for 10 years on that model and that's
you know that's great I'm glad that
stream that exists but for people who
are trying to have more interactivity in
their apps I think session state is only
going to get you so far
I'm sorry right in front of you
yeah yeah you yeah
so the cameras newly given I mean some
of those are interesting like
like adding and removing
yeah
on your website oh you know I forgot
because
really
I knew there was something I forgot
apparently a piece of here
uh and there's a requirements.txt in
there hopefully you know what to do yeah
if you talk about deployment so what
about to put the flip side of the high
dive world where it's like multi-user
story like is is when multiple people
get the same URL are they hitting the
same computational context or not yes
great question great question uh it's
actually
um I think a really surprising story for
a lot of people uh so it sort of left to
its own devices
one python process can serve end users
and you actually get to decide what data
you share and what data is isolated to
each session and uh it is actually as
simple as
um I'm not going to bring it up but
whatever reactives and state you put
inside of that server function is
specific to each session each session
does its own copy so that server
function it's called server should
really be called an IT session or
something like that probably
um every time someone arrives with a
fresh browser it runs that code so in
order to have a variable or a reactive
be shared across many sessions all you
have to do is just move that declaration
outside of the function and now you have
just one so uh it's very common and
shiny for R for example to have like we
have something called the reactive file
meter so you point it at a file and say
whenever this file changes I want to do
this and usually it's like read CSE or
something like that and then all of your
many many connected users can point to
that same reactive so when something
changes on disk the read CSV happens
once and then just the minimum amount of
recommendation happens across all the
sessions in order to make everybody up
to date I'm getting excited just talking
about it yeah I really love that aspect
of this model
uh maybe one more question and then
we'll call it
why not call it pie shiny
[Music]
we had many meetings
uh yeah I think
um
uh reasonable people can disagree about
names
um I I think I was more on the side of
pie shiny and
um
I think there are a couple things number
one do we have to go back and rename
shiny to our shiny if we do that and see
how many web pages are we gonna adopted
for that uh but also I think um like
from the marketing perspective like you
do have like a lot of web pages that
talk about shiny and I think at least
some people in the company felt like
we have to say shiny and pie shiny then
everywhere and you know so there were
just some sort of tactical problems at
itself but like to me pie shiny was the
first name that came to me and we were
sort of talked into doing shiny for
python yeah but you know I think it's at
the end of the day most people are not
going to be like context switching
between the two all the time so usually
it's pretty clear when you're talking
about one versus the other
all right again I will be uh by the
positive Booth uh here on the sixth
floor all day tomorrow I'd love to talk
to you thanks
[Applause]